Apple's huge WWDC event is coming in
just over a month and it looks like
recently confirmations show that we're
getting even more than we thought before
with some brand new leaks pointing at
some very exciting software changes as
well so let's jump right into it now of
course the news comes from Mark German
the most reliable Apple leaker out there
and he just posted a new edition of his
power on newsletter detailing exactly
what to expect at WWDC including the new
VR headset which will be called the
reality headset xros which is the
operating system for that some new Macs
revamped watch OS and more and
specifically he has some details on the
VR headset which is Apple's going to be
focusing on Sports gaming and fitness
apps and I'm gonna get into more detail
on that in just a minute but I do want
to mention that he did give us some
specifics on which maps are coming
including the 15-inch MacBook Air and he
even detailed the resolution and other
things we should expect including the
chip and other new Macs that are coming
and I'll definitely jump into that but
first I want to talk about the big watch
OS redesign because this is going to be
watch OS 10 which usually Apple does big
redesigns for the 10-year anniversary of
a certain product or Os so this is going
to feature a new home screen layout with
apparently folders so that's going to be
exciting and this leak actually comes
from a Twitter account analyst
941 and we don't really know how
reliable this guy is and specifically
Mark German even said many of the
details I've seen from this account are
not true so take that specific Leak with
a grain of salt but Mark German does say
that there is going to be some new
features with watch West 10. now moving
on to the VR headset just yesterday he
gave us a massive leak for what to
expect with the new reality headset
specifically he says Apple's working on
an arsenal of new apps and services for
the headset so the apple is going all
out they're going to try to blow
everybody away including collaboration
tools Sports viewing which means
basically watching real live sports
games in the headset with the super high
quality immersive display being right in
front of your eyes basically even better
than a movie theater experience with the
headset on he also specified a gaming
push which I have more details on from a
different leaker and workouts in VR
which I think is awesome because with
the Quest 2 from meta or Oculus a lot of
people love the workouts in VR like beat
saber basically being a really cool
workout he also said there would be
meditation almost like some kind of yoga
app that you can do and even supporting
eye scanning which might basically track
where your eyes are looking and enable
certain features that way but one of the
things that I'm most excited about is
that he says that new versions of
Apple's existing iPad features will come
to the VR headset he even said a big
part of the effort is adapting iPad apps
for the new headset which blends virtual
and augmented reality so right out of
the gate users will be able to access
millions of existing apps from
third-party developers via a new 3D
interface basically it's almost like a
rosetta 2 but for the VR headset
allowing tons of apps and games to be
instantly available on the VR headset
that is absolutely amazing the only
downside is that he says it'll be
roughly three thousand dollars and while
it will debut at wwtc it's going to be
going on sale months later probably
later in the fall now I actually spoke
to someone on Twitter Hachi the otter
who says he knows some Insider
information now I can't confirm any of
his details so take it with a grain of
salt but he says that apple is
redesigning their entire software teams
and they finish building a full-scale
apple games development section so I
asked him does that mean a dedicated AAA
gaming studio he said inside of Apple
yeah they are going all in so basically
Apple's making their own game studio
just like they have Apple TV plus where
they make their own shows and movies
they're literally making their own AAA
games with their own gaming studio going
even further he said that Apple
remodeled their entire engineering team
lineups to build games with unity and
Unreal Engine so basically they're
finally doing a big gaming push and he
said a lot of it is mixed with vros and
cross platform gaming so basically
people with the VR headset will be able
to play with people with other Apple
products so let's say you have an iPad
iPhone back they can all cross play at
the same time so if you choose to buy
Apple's VR headset you're not going to
be lonely there's going to be a huge
amount of people to play with right off
the bat but the beautiful thing about
this is that because Apple has switched
to metal across all products including
the Mac gaming developers can produce a
game just one time build it once and
then they can tweak it to support every
single Apple platform including VR and
he says the integration of vros in the
headset to Mac OS and iPad OS and iOS is
just unreal if they get the stuff
working right that was talked about is
going to be mind blowing so he says the
updates to Mac OS 13 and iOS 17 are
going to be enormous for this
integration so because of all that I'm
actually even more excited about the VR
headset than I was just a couple of
weeks ago I think if everything works
well with cross-platform gaming and
everything else it could actually be a
very cool product product now let's move
on to the max that we should expect and
the one we should expect for sure is the
15 inch MacBook Air which Mark German
has confirmed is likely coming at WWDC
however it might not come with an M3
Chip he says due to developer logs it's
looking like it's coming with an M2 with
the same 8 core CPU and 10 core GPU
layout and 8 gigs of RAM he even said
that the M3 chips are coming later which
hints at a fall release date for M3 and
the interesting thing is all of Mark
German's comments are matching up to
what Ross young is saying about a
15-inch MacBook Air coming soon as soon
as WWDC with the component production
underway and all of that also agrees
with what digit times said back in
February that the 15-inch MacBook Air
will have an m to ship and finally even
another source right here D then nice
that sheared that Apple has delayed
plans to introduce the M3 processor
based on tsmc's three nanometer
technology in MacBooks and will instead
use the M2 for the 15 inch according to
a media report saying that three
nanometer is really going to be helping
tsmc's Revenue in the third quarter
which starts in the fall and if you
needed another source we have Hachi the
tech otter who said that the 24 inch
iMac is apparently going to be coming
with the M2 Chip as a basic update he
says the first products coming with M3
are going to be the 13-inch MacBook Air
and 13-inch MacBook Pro no other Macs
are getting the M3 this year so I asked
him does the 15 inch get the M2 he says
it most likely will if it gets the M3 he
will be shocked and he even said that
right now apple has a massive surplus of
M2 chips and they need to find ways to
use them and that actually matches is up
to the report that we had that Apple
completely stopped M2 Chip production in
January and February because of slow M2
Max sales and when they resumed in March
they resumed at only 50 percent of
production showing that they do have a
surplus of M2 chips and apparently it's
so bad that this guy on Twitter says he
wouldn't be surprised if all of the
iPads got M2 chips because the M2 did
not sell anywhere near the M1 did so if
you might ask why would the 15-inch get
the M2 Chip there you go they have too
many of the M2 chips and they need to
sell them and the 15-inch MacBook gear
is the perfect height machine to do just
that and the crazy thing is back in
February Hachi the tech otter said that
the 24 inch iMac update would be mainly
the M2 Chip not the M3 like we were
expecting that Apple would skip the M2
but they probably will get the am2 chip
maybe even the M2 Pro because Apple's
not selling enough of them so we might
even get an M2 iMac at WWDC which would
be a very disappointing update but I
personally hope they wait until the M3
and the interesting thing is Mark German
did say that the new iMac is reportedly
in advanced stages of development and he
says it likely won't come until at least
the end of the year likely with the M3
chip so hopefully that's what Apple does
and in my opinion if the M3 chip comes
it has to come in the MacBook Air first
before the iMac which I think that iMac
would get delayed by about six months so
right here we have another article
saying that the M3 powered MacBook Air
is unlikely to debut at WWDC instead
coming sometime in the third quarter and
that comes from this leak right here
from economic Daily News saying that the
three nanometer chip has a delay and the
new Macbook Air 15 inch will come with
the old M2 Chip and that basically
confirms that the three nanometer M3
chip is only going to be coming until
after the three nanometer a17 ship later
this year so for now if we get any Max
at WWDC they're going to be based on the
M2 Chip or the M2 family of chips in the
case that we do get the Mac Pro so with
that said hopefully I didn't disappoint
too many of you with the 15 inch coming
with the M2 Chip but you let me know
your thoughts down in the comment
section below click the circle button
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
foreign